hi everyone welcome to another episode
of unlocking lily so I believe that this
world would be a better place if we all
just embrace who we truly are and when
after what we truly want which is what
inspired me to do just that start a
business to help people live the
extraordinary life on their terms
today Evan is helping me build a
business around my coaching and speaking
and I'm fighting all of you guys to join
me on my startup journey so the two main
things that I do for my business is I'm
a coach and a speaker so as a coach I
have the wonderful opportunity in
helping my clients find out who they
truly are and help them build a business
and life that they really want as a
speaker I've spoken at TEDx I've spoken
corporate events and private functions
and it all revolves around one theme
that theme is to unlock human potential
at the same time I'm also trying to help
myself grow both as a coach and as a
speaker so far I have read books I have
done online courses I've attended live
seminars and workshops I even have the
awesome help of my mentor Evan so the
next step for me is to reach out to
people that I believe have a unique set
of skills or a diverse background to
really learn from so that way I can
bring even more value to my clients and
the people I speak in front of so today
I am going to learn from mr. Josh Pais
Josh is an awesome human being he has
created this program called committed
impulse it's a high-performance training
program for anybody who wants to be
creatively invincible which is pretty
awesome amongst all of that Josh is also
a speaker no he's not amongst all of
that josh is also an actor an
entrepreneur and a coach so next up
you're gonna see my interview with Josh
Pais as we sit down to talk about his
mission and the
techniques that's going to help you
become creatively invincible enjoy what
I really really love about you is your
approach in how we handle different
types of emotion emotions that we
typically don't enjoy having like
nervousness anxiety fear and you you
touched upon it briefly earlier about
how they are just sensations that we
feel in a body and if we were not to
dramatize those sensations those
emotions it actually disappears within
seven to twelve seconds yes it is so
huge I don't know if you know how big
this is
it's it's nice I meant I know that it's
big and I know that that this concept is
it really is not about me but just that
note people put so much energy to try to
alter what they feel and it comes from
this notion that there's an ideal state
that we should strive to be in and the
truth of the matter in 20 years of
training people and experimenting is
that honestly we don't know what we're
going to feel we don't know what we're
gonna feel in two minutes from now
and so if we can honor that that this
biological system innocent from our
minds point of view is out of control
meaning it's gonna go here it's gonna go
there and for a part of our mind that's
disturbing
however it's not you know our mind goes
we're out of control but it's really
you're in control from your body's point
of view and what I work with is instead
of coming up with ways to overcome fear
to get rid of this to get rid is to
expand your tolerance for the full
spectrum of you and by if you can party
with whatever this sensation is like
then you have creative invincibility
I like your analogy about partying with
your emotions
whatever the situation is can you talk
more about that basically I mean if I
have any mantra before I'm shooting a
movie before you know before the cameras
about to roll or I'm in the I'm doing an
off-broadway play right now there's
anything that I say to myself before
going in to shoot something or teaching
a you know weekend course or whatever it
may be is is that I don't know I don't
know what I'm gonna feel and just to
remind myself to be in it it's like I
don't hang out with I don't know is a
really magical thing to do and since
grammar school you know it's been we're
conditioned I don't know is a bad thing
it means you're not prepared you did but
there's a real creativity and I don't
know and because if you just allow it to
you know your wonder to be there people
that take my class for a while like
they'll be like you know say what do you
feel right now just so that to make sure
they're connected to whatever's there
and let and create from that and people
that have been doing it for this work
for a while with me there'll be like I
feel anxious and like that's awesome
because that's something to connect to
if you want to be spontaneous and create
from your truth in this moment and
engage people
you have to just honor party with
wherever you are hmm
but if you're going like you know you
feel something and and you hold in your
mind oh that's a bad thing to feel or if
people saw that I felt this it would
mean that I wasn't professional or would
mean that I wasn't prepared whatever the
thought may be then you're gonna
disconnect from you and as soon as you
disconnect from I'll say your party your
body party simultaneously the audience
will disconnect from you and they will
go in their head if you're speaking with
people and you're in your head judging
how your yourself is doing or wondering
what they're thinking of you
it triggers them to go into their head
so if you can stay in you and breathe
like your bot your creativity is in your
body it's not in our intellect you stay
in your body and the most brilliant
thing work will come out I love it and
it seems so intuitive like it seems like
that's where we should be and get any
overdramatize things we intellectualize
things you know I go into like some kind
of existentialist bummer anytime like
someone looks at me in a different way
but you know it's all about having a
party in our body so it's yeah and the
party is always there it's always the
right thing and there's no you know
there's no bad sensation if you can get
that notion I mean I'm not talking about
you know getting hurt or something like
that but anything that's happening in
here if you can shift to that it's all
good because it's built into your DNA
this is how your were designed to feel
this full spectrum of sensation and it
you know I often think you know I was
walking through the woods one day and I
was just thinking about how to talk
about this stuff and it's almost like go
like going to the woods and going like
no that that plant is wrong yeah you
know that those bushes are wrong they're
not shouldn't be there it's the same
thing as going like this you know
feeling some calm you know that's wrong
feeling some it you know some intensity
some you know a lot of vibration in your
chest for example oh that's wrong it's
ridiculous and so again it's just if you
can expand your tolerance for all of you
it's like you're free Wow and and one
one thing that I do in my classes which
I would suggest is a great way to start
integrating this work is in my classes
anytime somebody goes in their head like
you know we'll be engaged with
whatever's happening and then somebody
is like you know
goes off you know I'm shopping and
Bloomingdale's in their head and like
walking down the aisles you know they're
just like and as soon as you're aware
that you've left everybody you say I'm
back it's a great thing just to do in
you know you can't always do it in the
middle of a meeting
but in your day to day life just
practicing like you can be walking down
the street and you realize wow I haven't
seen anything in front of me it's like
I'm back what do I take a breath what's
what is this information what do I
actually see and that just trains us to
stay in the moment and to be present I'm
back I'm back the more that you do it
you know in the beginning it's kind of
shocking to people because they were
like oh my god I'm back I'm back I'm
back but the more that you do it when
you'll be more and more present and then
when you do leave it'll be really clear
and you can come right back mm-hmm I
actually did that that exercise when I
did your online course and it was
amazing how many times I had to say I'm
back like and I thought I practiced
mindfulness and I practiced meditation
and I feel like I'm very present but
even after doing all of that I'm still
constantly telling myself I'm back it
could be something simple like oh what's
going out this water bottle I'm back
yeah so my mind kind of wanders and it's
so important to be present because I
feel like when we're not present we're
always either behind the time or ahead
of time which causes like stress exactly
instead of being right yet yeah I mean
our mind what our mind wants us to do is
to project about the future you know
it's either gonna be terrible or it's
gonna be better or reflect on the past
the past was better or I screwed up the
past and that's why everything's a mess
whatever so it's there's a part of our
brain that wants to constantly go to
past past and future and you know at one
point you know that was a survival
technique that was important but in
this era that is what causes all the
problems and I'm a PHA even in the world
like if we can really see and connect
with each other and let go of all these
stories that were carrying around and
I'm talking about globally it's like the
planet would shift but we kept our montt
there's a part of our minds that want to
carry a story and carry a grudge and get
justified and get revenge or whatever it
may be and when we're when that's
occurring we're in this thought loop
we're not engaged with what's actually
in front of each other it's like that I
don't know if it was I don't know the
story is I think it was I don't know it
was world war two or whatever where
there were some soldiers that for
whatever reason I'm screwing the story
up but the essence of it was that they
just stopped and they just really looked
at each other and they really saw this
this other human in front of them and it
was a really profound experience like
they were they couldn't fight each other
in that moment that is so beautiful Josh
I think that's a good place for us to
end this interview I I do I I see your
point and I see your mission as well
which is why I thought it was so
important to have you on our channel
because I think more people need to
learn about you and what you're about I
think there's a lot of programs out
there which is helpful in some sort of
way but I think there's a lot of like
you said suppressive qualities in it and
I think we can't suppress us and
ourselves anymore we need to be free and
what you said that when we're present
and we're human to human face to face
it's something magical and profound
happens it's a sense of understanding
it's a sense of our humanity and empathy
that we cannot get if we're not present
so I really really want to thank you for
that Josh thank you okay so that's it
that's my interview with
Josh I want to be respectful of his time
I know he's a busy guy so thank you so
much Josh do you have any just less I
know you said a lot of really amazing
things but last sentence to leave us
with today just have fun like see see
how much fun you can bring to the
smallest interaction whether its buying
some coffee with someone or whatever
work that you're about to do you know if
you have stuff you have to write or
whatever it may be if you can just
infuse fun in it it just is another way
to open the creative channel amazing
thank you so much Josh and thank you
guys for watching bye hey guys I am back
from the interview with Josh price and I
hope you guys enjoy the interview as
much as I did and I want to spend a
little bit of time going over the two
things that I learned from Josh that I
actually put into practice since meeting
him so the first thing that I learned
from him was party with the old eat
motion I love it I love this one because
I don't know I like to dance and I like
to party last week what I did was I
party about my emotions I had to film a
bunch of videos with Evan and that day
was like jam-packed I had workshops in
the afternoon to do I had to make the
video and in the morning I did a lot of
coaching session so I was like running
back and forth above all of that I was
actually really sick and I haven't been
sick in here so I was getting frustrated
with that too so I have all of these
things going on in my head and then I
had to make an awesome video at the same
time so instead of really using all of
the calming techniques that I used to
use before like calm down
I'm pretty all that kind of stuff which
which is good again it works but I
wanted to try Josh's technique as I was
going up the escalator going to the TDS
dance studio I said to myself oh boy I'm
feeling some bubbling coming up my
stomach into my chest and it's the
really hot is going to work my face and
you know I'm just gonna party with it
I'm fire raining all over the place and
I'm just gonna party with these emotions
I'm gonna make this work I'm not gonna
try to suppress anything so I got to the
studio I was like completely like hey
I'm party with my emotions I was like
really high-energy and I saw Evan and
Jason was that Cameron % and it was fun
it was a lot of fun we had some fun with
the video as well and you know what that
nervousness anxiety that I was feeling
it actually disappeared within a few
seconds of me really just letting it be
letting my emotions be as it is and
they're all are just sensations and I
walked away feeling like you know what I
represented myself
number two is I'm back our presence is
so incredibly important not only for
herself but for every single person that
we encounter how many times have we been
in a situation where we're sitting
across from someone and we feel like
they're just not listening to us it just
doesn't feel great does it and how many
times have we been that person who's not
listening so over the last week after
talking to Josh I really started
practicing I'm back technique so every
time my mind would wonder I would bring
it back over and over again and now in
the beginning it was like all the time
and then later on as I did it more and
more I became more present and I had to
say it less and less so I really want to
challenge all of you to go on this
journey with me of presence because I'm
gonna continue to do this and I want you
guys to do it with me as well so every
time your mind wanders tell yourself
that you're back you know how to stand
out loud but just say it in your mind
and see how much more focused you are
and see how much clearer you are because
I have seen the benefits of that so I
want to pass it over to you guys as well
so in addition to do the interview with
Josh I'm also enrolled in his online
course called committed impulse so if
you guys did harrassing you want to find
out more information about his course I
will have it in the links below as well
as a link to a free 20 minute lesson to
kind of check it out and see how you
feel about the course as well and I'm a
special shout out for Steven Harris
Steven thank you so much for writing
that awesome comments in my last episode
and I hope you and your family are
having a wonderful time and finally the
question of the day is which part of
this video was your favorite
you can name anything from the interview
from the techniques that we talked about
I'm really curious to find out so leave
in the comments below and I'll join in
on the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching and more importantly being
on this journey with me I feel like I'm
just getting started and I feel the
comfort in knowing that all of you guys
are going along with me every step of
the way so thank you guys again and I'll
see you very very soon
one wrong move yeah the most important
work ever if you have to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple so it would be kind
of like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details